hello my name is Scott Phillips game
director on Assassin's Creed syndicate
today we're playing as Jacobs twin
sister Evie the master of stealth Evie
has her own unique story skill tree and
stealth abilities this is what we call a
black box mission where you choose your
own path to achieve your goal lots of
God's predictably patrol news
thorn may already be inside
that's a stick to the shadows we are now
approaching the iconic Tower of London
Evy suspects that the vault of the tower
might contain the Shroud pieces of Eden
are artifacts created by the ancient
first civilization and our sources of
great power each of the doors to the
tower is being watched by royal guards
to avoid attracting too much attention
let's find another way in
let's use the iconic assassin rope
launcher to scale the building we're now
reaching the vantage point highlighted
by the Eagle icon vantage points are the
starting points for all of our black box
missions black box missions follow the
Assassin's Creed syndicate 360
philosophy it's about giving the players
a goal and letting them choose how to
achieve it in this mission we need to
assassinate Lucy thorne a powerful
Templar also looking for the shroud is
the key find it and bring it to me
okay's
Queen Victoria's Keys past Queen
Victoria's Keys just seen hints on
different approaches to the mission it's
up to you to decide whether to choose an
opportunity presented or create your own
opportunity based on your play style
before we continue the walkthrough let's
have a quick look at two of the
different paths
the first option will show is stealing
the tower master key you need to steal
the master key from the guard captain
then you need to make your way unnoticed
to the top of the tower then enter the
locked door and steep past Lucy's guard
and surprise the target from above but
let's choose another path our second
option is to liberate the constable
taken hostage by the Templar we need to
infiltrate the building first take out
the Templars inside the house use the
new voltaic bomb incapacitating multiple
enemies at once get the key to the room
where the constable is locked in get the
constables help to rally his troops and
take the Templars head-on
but let's choose another path one that
better suits and highlights Evie's
unique stealth capabilities in the
opening sequence we saw a guard
attacking an imposter
let's go see what's going on the
player's options are highlighted in the
environment with different icons we want
to reach the sky like on to investigate
this opportunity we will need to be
careful not to get detected by the Royal
Guards in charge of patrolling the tower
in order to reach the guard will use
Evie's chameleons ability as we have to
go through the garden this skill is
unique to Evie and allows her to become
virtually invisible to the enemy even on
open ground once Evie has acquired the
chameleon skill it will trigger
automatically when you stay still in
stealth mode this skill is also
available in the open world when you're
playing as Evie
this is the guard we saw at the
beginning of the mission he is a Tower
of London guard and a friend of Henry
Greene the master assassin of London we
need to reach him and talk with him one
of Greene's friends onto
thank heavens you've come that thorn
woman has Templars everywhere disguise
as God's I think I could pass as one of
them long enough to sneak you inside
except the gods out here already know my
face we need to deal with them first
meet me by the White Tower when you're
ready he tipped us on the presence of
Templars disguised as guards in the
Tower of London we need to take them out
allowing us to get closer to our target
we can use eagle vision to identify our
enemy and take a closer look at the
environment we have identified one of
the disguised Templar guards the real
tower guards are highlighted in blue we
need to be careful not to be spotted by
them as their job is to protect the
tower once again we see the chameleon
skill in action allowing Evie to get
close to her target unnoticed one
Templar cart out one to go
another one of Evie's unique skills is
knife master allowing her to carry more
throwing knives and inflict more damage
with them than her brother this suits
Evie's stealthy style a simple headshot
take care of the enemy from a distance
ensuring we remain undetected for the
time being now that we've taken out both
Templar guards let's get back to our
guard Ally
that's all for the men out here what's
next
miss thorn wants me captured if she sees
me in Chains she might let her guard
down can you make it look convincing you
mean pretend like all my prisoner I'll
do my best man
if we get too close those Templars might
realize I'm not one of theirs then let's
keep our distance Evie is pretending as
if she was captured to safely get close
to her target however the player remains
in complete control of Evie and the
guard as you can see there is a circle
below Evie you need to make sure you
keep your enemies away from that
detection circle or they will figure out
something is wrong inform miss thorne
I'm bringing in the assassin
as if the likes of you can stand up to
miss dawn we are now getting closer to
our target our strategy seems to be
working and we're passing right under
the nose of the Templars protecting Lucy
thorn I found her wandering inside the
walls man what you want to speak with
her welcome miss Froy do you care to
tell me where the shroud is
as you wish I shall find it without your
help
and then I'll strangle you with it watch
her closely I hope you never find the
Shroud you have no idea what it truly
can do tell me then those were just a
few of the options available to complete
this mission and only a taste of the 360
philosophy you will see throughout
Assassin's Creed syndicate join the
family get rewards reserved now for
exclusive access to the Darwin and
Dickens conspiracy available October
23rd